As Moore put it out, correlation can help us decide
which variables are related. But even correlation coefficients can be deceptive
if you're not careful. Plotting your data is the best way
to help you understand it and it can lead you to
key insights. Let's consider another data set that comes with the
alr3 package. You'll need to install this package first and then
make sure you load it. The data set that we're going to
load is called the Mitchell Data Set. The Mitchell Data Set
contains soil temperatures from Mitchell, Nebraska.
And they were collected by Kenneth
G Hubbard from 1976 to 1992. By working with this data set,
we'll see how correlation can be somewhat deceptive. So, for your first
task, I want you to create a scatter plot of temperature versus months.